on va parler aujourd'hui à notre
émission tam-tam canada des déboires des
petits plaisirs enivrant du temps des
fêtes auxquelles se livrent les
canadiens et les québécois en cette
période de festive et on va découvrir à
l'occasion le visage de vrai visage de
montréal qui de puissantes en est la
ville canadienne du vice et des plaisirs
nocturnes wifi et on salue comme ça de
la main un bon bonjour à nos auditeurs
et on peut pas les appeler les
téléviseurs parce qu'ils sont ils nous
regardent comme ça ce sont les gens qui
se trouvent sur facebook l'indre en ce
moment alors bienvenue parmi nous avec
nous aujourd'hui autour de la table ont
fait le tour on commence à la gauche
bonjour arradi radis bay et que notre
angoisse du côté français et puis à
marivan de l'espace francophone l'espace
et puis aussi et léo gimeno qui est
notre second webmestre secteur espagnol
latina musicale de radio-canada
international vous voulez on va ouvrir
votre micro et un petit problème on peut
pas ça change la chance c'est
merveilleux écouter avant qu'on commence
avant qu'on glisse vers notre sujet de
la semaine montréal qui salivent tout ça
j'aimerais n'avait plus que microsoft
ait fait plus de voix non plus c'est
vous qui avait disparu je vais crier
alors je vais vous je vais proposer en
icône tranquillement je vais vous
proposer de glisser vers notre sujet
avec cette vidéo vidéo virale qui a fait
le tour du monde cette semaine ça se
passe justement à montréal vous nous
décrivez la sainte marie brièvement
alors un matin tout à fait normal du
mois de décembre où tout le monde sait
conduire une voiture un hiver au canada
et au québec mais sans que ce matin la
jeune quotas m'ont rien centre-ville de
montréal
les autobus ont emboîté emboîter les
voitures suivi des dépanneuses des
voitures de police enfin c'était
incroyable voici ce que ça donne
là plusieurs copies de cette vidéo qui
ont été reproduites au total 25 millions
de vues à travers le monde
jeudi soir tout un dérapage voici une
des meilleures versions c'est un peu
polonais
vous allez retourner reconnaître le
style de bénir l'on écoute on regarde ça
s'en vient
[Musique]
et
oui
[Musique]
alors voilà ce qui se passe lorsqu'on a
trop bu derrière le volant ici à mon
rien en fait on avait oublié des ventes
du sel tout simplement sur cette partie
de la côte du beaver hall à montréal
réaction du maire hier en anglais il ya
eu un petit mot l'apôtre paul issus des
choses qui arrivent mais je pense qu'il
est usé le mot au merde en anglais
voilà donc la ville de montréal se pose
ou un peu olé olé notre affaire
d'ailleurs avant combes qu'on aille plus
loin j'ai une petite surprise pour vous
vous allez comprendre tout de suite le
monde y est puisque on pense à toi je
vois divers qu allons-nous voir dit vous
avez pas du cru c'est un terroir
parce que c'est chila c'est sa chair on
a vu ici je vais apporter les fonds de
bouteilles c'est parce que c'est tout ce
qu'il a déjà vous voulez un mari voulait
servir parce que moi j'ai les mains sur
le volant
non si je buvais vous savez cette
émission sera encore plus de connaître
justement aller c'est un peu un petit
instant je ne sais pas je conduis en
réalité je dois conduire après cette
émission pour vous mouiller les bêtes
ils sont d'accord
tolérance zéro on va le mettre comme ça
là comme symbole d'amitié avec 60
sentait ça fait plus en temps comme ça
que montréal est vraiment la destination
pour le plaisir et surtout dans les
années 20 1920 prohibition aux états
unis les américains venaient new york
est beau ce temps pour s'amuser
et oui exactement ça n'a pas changé
d'ailleurs cette semaine la ville de
montréal a obtenu un nouveau statut du
gouvernement du québec
vu de ce qu'ils appellent ce tu devais
le jour particulière distingue de ce
format
colin statut particulier et elle pourra
décider de leur et de fermeture de sebha
et les choses pourraient se rallongent
et donc nous on ferait fermerait plus à
3 heures on fermerait à 5h30
ça fait réagir nos auditeurs
mais d'abord les réactions de nos
auditeurs à notre question tu entames
écoute on y vient
30 tranquillement au niveau pour
l'alcool soit à proscrire une bonne
pression pourrait être dans kadri la
consommation d'alcool ou l'alcool offert
ça peut être de distribuer nombre de
coupons données et les oueds données
pour des breuvages alcoolisés
ça peut être aussi de permettre un accès
facile aux breuvages non alcoolique
c'est des milliards c'est pour des
milliers non non non c'est 100
millilitres je sais peut-être à vérifier
oui j'en veux être donc il nous dit
c'est un fléau dans ce pays
les jeunes se gavent se tue mais
personne ne dit rien c'est disponible 24
heures sur 24 partout à eséka il n'y a
pas de il n'y a pas de pharmacie me lie
à des pots de brasserie
soyons sérieux je suis choquée car moi
même je suis jeune et quand je vois
d'autres comme moi se tuer dans cela je
suis triste merci d'avoir soulevé ce
sujet merci de nous avoir écrit beaucoup
quand même quoi me jouait à l'honorer je
pense qu'il manque de l'armée au
cameroun enfin j'ai été voir sur sa page
d'histoire et puis il est habillé comme
un militaire où il appuie la mission de
certains militaires on voit des images
de lui dans un aéroport
vincent côté du québec écrit en arrivons
la chose suivante alors il dit dans
n'importe quoi ce sont les excès qui
sont problématiques vous le savez tous
par exemple si vous consommez trop
d'alcool vous deviendrez alcoolique et
souffrirait à long terme de problèmes de
santé reliés à cette surconsommation
buvait trop d'eau et votre corps ne s'en
portera pas très bien parlez-en à votre
médecin
l'excès et dans tous les cas le problème
et anne marie avec votre bel accent
france a jamais mieux vous entendre lire
cette lettre du québec envoyés par les
rigoles savoir c'est l'alcool c'est un
problème parce que ça m'a vraiment comme
ça que c'est écrire mais illégal il
illégal
il est légal en tout cas régale même
chance pour la cigarette consommer c'est
un choix c'est à vous de faire ce choix
et non à toi d'en juger
donc nous tu toi c'est très familier ses
p continuer à parler moi je continue à
bois
écoutez que c'est le parti ici on sent
que vous consommez
c'est pas toujours le cas il y avait un
sondage en tout le monde parlait de ça
la radio cette semaine à tous les postes
c'est le fait que 37% un sondage récent
réalisé au québec où on s'aperçoit que
37% des gens qui ont participé au party
de noël au travail ont une petite
affaire une petite aventure du taureau
là il s'est passé quelque chose
conjointe de campagne quand je vois
qu'un jour j'en connais qui sont devenus
les conjoints parachute en tout cas un
mari jobin a abordé cette question est
très délicate avec maître pierre pilot
associé chez la firme d'avocats gowlings
dabriou hadji bureau de montréal où il
se spécialise en droit du travail et de
l'emploi
voici un extrait de cette entrevue
ce n'est pas que l'alcool soit à
proscrire
une bonne pratique pourrait être dans
kadri la consommation d'alcool ou l
alcool offert ça peut être de distribuer
nombre de coupons données et les oueds
sonné pour des breuvages alcoolisés
ça peut être aussi de permettre un accès
facile aux breuvages non alcoolisées ça
peut aussi être de choisir ou limitée
soit d alcool offert souvent dans des
événements stratégie bain ça peut
frapper fort hills et georges de genre
de situation peut occasionner des
dérapages
donnez nous des exemples de cas où ça
dérape y est il a fallu peut-être que
l'employeur revoilà s'asseoir dans un
cas ou non plus à la fête dans un
restaurant cinq soirées on a un employé
si éméché ne retrouve pas son manteau
tout ce qu'elle devienne une crise dans
le restaurant lance une chaîne menace le
propriétaire en lui grâce et les jambes
c'est une situation où l'employeur est
justement pour être tenu responsable de
la limite
ben et puis vous savez que l'employé
d'un joli coup le milieu des coûts des
dommages 1 mais deuxièmement il ce genre
de comportement qui peut porter atteinte
à la réputation de l'employeur de
l'entreprise donc ça c'est une situation
où l'emploi yaro dû agir l'employé en
question s'est vu imposer la intentions
distension de cinq jours sans solde
dans une autre affaire sauf et c'est pas
anecdotique changer tout heureux tout ce
qu'on voit régulièrement un employé un
peu éméchés à la fin de la soirée venait
de s'adresser à son supérieur pour lui
livrer le fonds a pensé à régler de
vieux comptes comme on dit et régler de
vieux comptes
et si le genre des changes qui peut
dégénérer si bien que
dans le cas où le supérieur lui est dans
un état satisfaisant savoir quinzaine il
a manifestement le champion alors voilà
des recettes aux employeurs pour mieux
contrôler la situation et éviter les
débordements lors du party de noël
pauvres employés
on n'arrête pas même le jour de noël ou
avant il faut se contrôler réaction des
essais des commentaires qui sont étaient
qui ont été livrés au cours des
reportages que nous nous entrevue que
l'on fait sur l'alcool au fil des trois
dernières années conduit qu'on a notre
nouveau site web
on a produit environ 2 % de nos articles
presque 2 % de nos articles sur 7000 et
plus avaient un lien avec l'alcool bon
bien sûr parce qu'on a beaucoup parlé de
20 des brasseries des nouveaux produits
en voyez c'est ça c'est notre stock de
formation moi je même j'ai fait des
affaires sur le cidre de glace et bon
mois monde défend on aborde des
questions plus sérieuses comme les
risques associés à la surconsommation
non seulement dans les parts et noël
mais évidemment sur nos hôtes
sylviane gauthier au québec radi nous
envoyer le commentaire suivant il ya
quelques temps j'étais ouverte à l'idée
à montréal il ya deux ans gardé les bars
ouverts jusqu'à 6 heures du matin afin
de permettre aux gens qui ont trop bu de
laisser l'alcool s'est dissipée mais pas
dans le but de leur faire boire encore
plus c'est cher et continuent de boire
jusqu'à 6h à ça devient première fête
5h30 et 6h là on fermerait le bas on
leur donne une demi heure pour se
dégriser
est-ce que c'est ici mettez à 6 heures
le matin en principe les enfants réseau
de bus scolaires prennent la route et ça
donc ça fait peur fait en dix ans à
l'ailé sans consommer de l'alcool
jusqu'à 5h30 du matin
vous venez d'exposer encore plus de gens
aux risques liés aux abus de la de
consommation d'oeufs et de personnes
irresponsables car beaucoup plus de gens
sont sur les routes à ces heures-là avez
vous imaginez les dégâts d'une personne
ivre au volant sur l'heure de pointe du
matin
en tout cas le débat est relancé par ce
que ça a été lancé il ya deux ans
maintenant que montréal à son nouveau
statut cette semaine statut de ville
particulière distinctes et spéciale au
québec
le maire
coderre va maintenant avant lé pouvoir
de décider à cadencer barbe ont fermé et
ça pourrait revenir comme ça comme
proposition marie-hélène gitans à
rebours au québec anne marie écrit alors
elle dit quelles décisions absurdes n'y
at-il pas déjà suffisamment de problèmes
avec l'alcool qu'il faille en rajouter
j'espère que les montréalais se rendre
compte que ce n'est encore qu'une
histoire bien commercial aux dépens de
leur santé alors on sur un steam
peut-être notre capacité à absorber tous
ces conducteurs livre sur nos routes
faire un pataquès meehan a quand même
beaucoup moins non je reste un peu
surprise devant tout ça parce que je me
dis au fil des ans il n'y a pas moins de
conducteurs us sur les routes vous avez
pas la belle famille que j'ai moins tape
à opération nez rouge
une opération qui permet donc d'avoir
des conducteurs responsables qui vous
ramène à la maison si vous avez trop de
ça fonctionne à des grandes villes
anne-marie mais quand vous habitez à la
campagne dans l'alberta comme les gens
de ma belle famille vous faites quoi
vous prenez votre camion votre pk il
faut reprenez la wii et puis vous avez
un accident votre assureur vous
connaissez votre troisième état
d'ébriété mais ça va vous avez encore
tué personne je dis ça va ça va vous
coûter dix mille dollars pour vous en
sortir pour échapper à la prison vous
primes d'assurance vont vont exploser il
va y avoir un divorce en famille je
raconterai pas une histoire personnelle
c'est captivant gt gt cup attendez la
suite avec impatience
moi j'attends le reportage avec
impatience une entrevue de dédier aux ti
avec stéphane murray directeur général
d'alcoa prévention canada qui explique
que l'attitude des canadiens les gars
d'alcool est étonnant ils ont une
opinion trop élevé de leurs capacités
alors qu'ils sont ivres dans les
voitures est ce que les autorités
peuvent faire quelque chose
[Musique]
alors on en reçoit des de toutes les
couleurs des lettres nouveau voici une
lettre envoyée par dominic léveillé au
québec qui nous parle des conséquences
d'alcool au volant
et puis on va demander qu'ils veulent à
lire cette lettre ses traits à l'origine
il dit j'habite lanaudière donc
lanaudière c'est au nord est de montréal
pas très loin d'ici
lis je connais personnellement des
membres de la famille qui a perdu une
mère de trois jeunes enfants
waouh dont le père a été blessé et est
devenu veuf en quelques secondes le
jeune de 22 ans qui a causé cette
hécatombe était en état d'ébriété il
faut attaquer le problème à sa source
interdire la publicité faisant la
promotion de l'alcool associés
habituellement au plaisir à une détente
où l'insouciance est de mise
où on nous présente la halle comme
l'alcool comme étant une forme de
récompense socialement validé quasi
obligatoire et il ou elle c'est
dominique rajoute le ministère du revenu
pourrait perdre quelques sous ace a eu
une elle s est ce que c'était pour wii
est so us peut-être un mais notre ras le
cul donc régie de l'assurance maladie du
québec
nos services sociaux notre taux de
criminalité risquerait de s'emporter là
il manque un mot je pense que c'est
mieux
luis emporté quelque chose oui je m'en
s'en porter mieux de quoi s'emporte et 1
est ce qu'il faut pour repousser l'âge
de la conduite automobile sachant que
les jeunes - avec qui l'ont pas atteint
un certain degré de maturité mais au
plan moteur physique ils sont très
récents 6 et 16 ans n'est ce pas conduit
la conduite oui oui c'est pas comme ça
où l'alcool pour les jeunes c'est celle
au wi fi nancer 06 ont accueilli dans le
faut jusqu'à je sais pas si ses 21 ans
quelque chose comme ça si vous avez un
permis de conduire d'apprentis isimat
seule chose que je sais c'est juste ça
fait longtemps j'ai depuis 18 ans
vous pouvez pas conduire avec un seul
vin continue ses roues d'alcool parce
que à moins qu'une personne à côté
annoncé non c'est faux on pouvait tout
simplement pas conduire vous allez
obtenir trop de pointe des mairies que
vous allez perdre votre la première
année du permis de conduire donc entre à
partir du moment où on prend son permis
de conduire ça peut être à partir de 16
ans 17 ans que l'on choisit on doit être
accompagné pendant toute la première
année on ne peut pas conduire seul toute
la première année mais on part on peut
pas même pas avoir les chauffeurs
accompagnant yves raconté à nbc n'a
imaginé les papayes abu leil qu'il ya
quelqu'un qui propose c'est un chercheur
canadien qui le docteur ross qu'à
l'université du nord de la
colombie-britannique donc sur la police
canadienne qui a proposé qu'on repousse
large des du de felou pour conduire au
canada simplement parce que les jeunes
sont irresponsables ils sont destinés à
prendre d'alcool il ya conduire en même
temps l'auteur karan affirme qu'une
modification de la législation sur l'âge
légal pour boire au canada pourra aussi
avoir un impact national majeur sur les
jeunes conducteurs mais il repousserait
à 19 ans ben écoute et on avait préparé
pour vous un extrait de reportage comme
un âne et un an comme c'est une fuite en
avant des problèmes
rien ne va plus faites bouge on écoute
sur l'alcool change des comportements
des possibilités on sait bien que des
jeunes hommes sont déjà plus impulsive
que les jeunes femmes on sait que
l'alcool change la façon qu ils sont
impulsifs leur comportement alexander
godard est là et médecin spécialiste en
toxicomanie
il a pris toutes les causes de mortalité
des jeunes hommes et jeunes femmes après
avoir l'âge minimum d'alcool de 18 ans
de passer pays
dix neuf ans dans l'autre tracy regarder
les mises en cause l'action de voitures
des meubles ou d'empoisonnement et il ce
qu'il a trouvé ce qu'il ya immédiatement
après des plages de 18 ans de 19 ans il
y ait 10 % 15 % la mortalité
alors ce qu'il a trouvé il a demandé si
si on change l'âge minimum légal pour
boire de l'alcool à l'âge de 21 ans
peut-être on peut éviter une portion de
ces de ces vitamines des réalités que
même s'il âgé de 21 ans il va y avoir
toujours des hommes qui vont avoir accès
à l'alcool avant l'âge de la bio n'en
est ce qu'on a vu même aux états unis
fécamp d'un minimum chance s'il augmente
ou celles d'essence a des impacts et
nancy quand on commence à avoir accès à
l'aide à l'alcool
d'ailleurs un groupe de jeunes tuant
amar accès à l'alcool avant la gym mais
ça va changer
le total indeed aussi l'âge légal pour
consommer
cette mesure a été discutée mais qui
n'est pas très populaire tant auprès de
la population que auprès d'el islah tard
en fait le raisonnement c'est que si on
est majeur est vital on a le droit de
vote
comme tous les droits cinéma d'un adulte
pourquoi est-ce qu'on arrête aussi le
droit de consommer de l'alcool
marie claude morin porte-parole de madd
canada il ya des côtes intérêt aussi
entre autres l'industrie des boissons
alcoolisées qui serait
très opposée elle mesure comme celle
alors ce qu'on propose plutôt ce sont
des mesures pour un cadre i la conduite
automobile chez les jeunes conducteurs
kinko nécessairement de leur interdire
la consommation mais bien de faire en
sorte que lorsqu'il ya consommation mais
que les gens ne prennent pas le volant
présentement il ya ce qu'on appelle
tolérance zéro finama qui est imposé au
jeune comte paris ou nouveau contrat
aussi alarmant plusieurs juridictions la
proche qui a été favorisé c'est
seulement pour justement ce tolérance et
croûtons aucun alcool
si on n'allait pas sans de conduire pour
les hommes jusqu'à 21h ou 22h dépendant
des juristes dois vous dire qu'il ya eu
plusieurs choses qui sont régulièrement
ramener dans les discussions l'âge légal
pour consommer aussi est un sujet qui
revient régulièrement dans les
discussions entre autres toute la
question doit-on permettre par exemple à
des jeunes qui n'ont pas atteint l'âge
de consommer de le phare soutien
parental par exemple alors ce qu'on sait
c'est que lee les recherches d'un
internat maintenant nous démontre que
plus on retarde finalement le début de
la consommation d'alcool
si on peut par exemple convaincre les
jeunes attendent à 21,28 même 25 avant
de consommer de l'alcool on les protège
à plusieurs niveaux tant au niveau
physiologique
parce qu'évidemment à cet âge à leur
corne peut entièrement fini de se
développer entre autres le cerveau et on
lit on y vient finalement de les exposer
à tout autre risque grossesse non
désirée par exemple ou de la violence et
des nantes en tulle le sujet qui nous
intéresse nous plus parce qu leur mal à
contrer crédit
[Musique]
alors voilà j'espère que cette
suggestion sera au moins des battues
qu'elle ne tombera pas comme comme une
goutte dans l'océan
petits tests quiz ici un petit quiz
on va appeler ça le quiz canada tient
voyons si vous savez combien ça coûte
boire choix au canada
régulièrement combien en moyenne les
canadiens dépensent ils chaque année
pour acheter leur alcool beaucoup mais
oui cher plusieurs milliers de dollars
mais encore en dollars six mille dollars
ces mineurs par personne le revenu moyen
d'un canadien ça tourne autour des 42 43
dollars qui dit mieux
moi je moi je dirais plutôt 2000 je
trouve que ça fait beaucoup quand même
et vous êtes très proche de la 622 $
pour les ontariens 1 mais c'est pas bon
c'est tout c'est tout ben voilà 1271
pour les gens qui habitent dans le grand
nord où le ton parce que là évidemment
tout est le double du prix oui il est
québécois qui sont quand même des gens
assez modérée dans leur élan vers la
colle un peu plus cher 788 $ mais ça
c'est sada des chefs de nat 2-2 et une
couple d'années alors que essais par
personne donc c'est pas parce par foyer
la cepal de mariée la femme laval et
consoloc mari une femme ça coûterait à
peu près 1500 $
je vous donne les cheveux que j'ai la
fume un plus imagine à la laverie et se
sont évités important pour le
gouvernement pour soigner tous ces
malades à 6 avec une moyenne en fait ce
n'est qu'une moyenne si on paie une
bouteille de vin 20 $ et qu'on en achète
deux par semaine
ça montre un oui donc ça coûte cher au
québec que ça coûte un petit peu moins
cher parce que la société des alcools du
québec créée en 1920 pour ceux qui s'y
intéressent donc qui fait partie des
belles années des années folles de mots
rien ils ont diminué un peu leur prix il
ya un mois environ pour s'aligner sur
une politique de prix semblable à celle
de l'ontario d'accord là où ça coûte
moins cher pour pas que les gens fassent
eux le pont et un petit moment mario
propre pays
mais la sélection est supérieur au
québec je peux vous en parler parce que
je fais le commerce dans l'es2 export
alcool moi je connaissais vous savez
qu'il ya moins de des règles en fait
sont plus flexibles du côté anglophone
au québec il ya plus des règles c'est
pour ça que dans une marque
quiconque veut pas de l'argent simplexa
notation on trouve plus des offres en
pond way on peut aussi on trouve 1 2 de
l'autre côté 5,6 différentes je mets ma
parce qu'ils sont pas passées toutes les
lamentations
bon moi je me limite ou beaujolais c'est
tout ce que je sais je vois que vous
avez presque tous terminés votre alcool
séminaire fort en studio ça sent comme
un peu les robinets c'est un terme très
québécois pour des coûts des gens qui
boivent un peu d'alcool mais là on est
un éditeur américain qui nous a demandé
d'effectuer une petite recherche pour
lui pour savoir si les jeunes canadiens
font comme les jeunes américains ils
font du binge drinking vous allez sur la
page web de tam-tam canada d'en fouiller
dans nos archives
vous allez voir c'est un des c'est ce
qu'on vous offre cette semaine ça c'est
se saouler à outrance et un bois en bois
jusqu'à ce que mort s'ensuive jugent
qu'être confiant sont par terre
avons pu lever le codho - minimum c'est
assez indigne des fois quand on voit des
photos et des vidéos de perception
tellement bu qu'elles ont complètement
perdu le privé oui il devrait être
interdit la mobilité à côté d'eux me
fait comme ça c'est ça non non vraiment
je fais un peu comme le policier là pour
voir si je vous ai pas des facultés
affaiblies
oui yoro de téléphone pour joindre
l'équipe de tomtom canada pour nous
poser une question ou nous proposer un
prochain thème des missions tam-tam 809
radis peut-être 5 9 7
oui 07/09 celle avantage de ne jamais
boire à leonera au des alertes e mail
numéro une personne qui nous a appelés
je suis sûr qu'elle n'a pas pris un
verre de trop mais elle s'est trompé
d'endroit
elle a même un problème en particulier
on peut qu'on peut pas régler on écoute
c'est amusant ça fait partie de
l'actualité cette semaine au canada
[Musique]
dans lequel invite je veux faire lisa
vous avec ma carte je sais comment faire
patricia beaucoup de bordelais merci au
revoir on peux pas l'aider avec son
compère mince on peut faire bien des
choses mais on n'a pas encore
l'autorisation du gouvernement pour
rejouer dans les comptes des gens comme
ça un peu le contraire ment c'est ainsi
la fidélisation plein régime deux points
de fidélisation canada qui a fait la
manchette beaucoup depuis une dizaine de
jours ils ont décidé qu'il fallait vider
nos points accumulés plus que cinq ans
c'est fini
ben là ils ont changé d'idée il ya eu
pression de la part d'une province en
ontario pour un projet de loi pour que
les compagnies comme ça ne puisse pas
imposer des limites et puisse pas
enlever les points que les gens ont
gagné au fil des des achats surtout que
les airs mais ça prend tellement de
temps qu'il est entre nous mais j'ai
découvert hier soir un truc pour un
accumulé 1 à chaque dollar à celle du
dollar que vous dépensez mais je vous
donnerai pas le nom de la compagnie ce
serait de la publicité gratuite mais
vous plus écrire @ rcnm point ca c'est
fini la merci beaucoup pour cette
semaine à dubaï d'être venu aujourd'hui
avec new wave maistre et aux webmasters
côté français le titre chef c'est
semaine c'est
et puis à n'arrivons avant ce qui t'est
espace autochtones qu'est-ce qu'on
retrouve cette semaine
à les écouter la chronique de mélissa
mollen dupuis parce que c'est une
question que tout le monde se pose quand
on est un allochtone donc non autochtone
on se dit mais pourquoi les autochtones
ils payent pas d'impôts erreur mais bien
sûr mais ceux qui vivent hors réserve
paye de l'impôt et ceux qui vivent dans
une réserve n'en paye pas mais vous
allez comprendre pourquoi il n'en payent
pas il ya des très bonnes raisons
excellent voilà merci et à la semaine
prochaine tous nos auditeurs et
téléviseurs à travers